na keine Zeit für die Wiesen
na Ihnen kann geholfen werden wir sind
stolz Ihnen unsere aktionsbox Wiesen to
go präsentieren zu können mit unserer
Jenny aus dem geschulten Serviceteam
erleben Sie einen typischen wiesenbesuch
in nur 30 Sekunden die Oktoberfest ist
Sense sozusagen und das tolle daran sie
haben so noch mehr Zeit für ihren
stressigen und dämlichen Job
bereit ja na dann los Jenny Stufe 1 die
perfekte Kleidung
Stufe 2 Bierzeltatmosphäre
unser neu entwickelter
wiesengeruchscocktail aus echtem Schweiß
Urin und frisch Erbrochenen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herrlich und jetzt Stufe 4 ein zünftiger
Rausch
mit dieser 100-prozentigen
alkoholinjektion sind sie schon in
kürzester Zeit sternhagelblau und
brauchen sich nicht erst umständlich und
langwierig 10 Mars hinter die Binde zu
knallen genial oder Ortschaft ist wie
auf der Wiesn genial oder jetzt fehlt
noch Stufe 5 Diebstahl gut gemacht Jenny
und wenn sie wiesen to go jetzt
bestellen gibt es gratis noch ein paar
auf die Fresse dazu
typisch Wiesen herrlich das ist die
schönste süße meines Lebens
die Essenz von Wiesen in nur 30 Sekunden
mit Wiesen to go
[Applaus]